c'est une affaire compliquée que doit
juger cette semaine les assises de saône
et loire ce 18 décembre 2012
l'accusé en instance de divorce avec son
épouse veut faire constater un adultère
le persuader que l'avocat sollicité par
son épouse est aussi son amant ce
jour-là l'avocat des jeunes avec sa
cliente effet à la sortie du restaurant
que l'accusé aurait porté des coups à
mettre du monde des faits quand oniam
chara qui a réfuté catégoriquement
l'avocat des parties civiles
interpellent m dumont a dit avoir subi
des violences
diani vous qu'il a menti il a dit des
choses inexactes répond l'accusé paix à
son âme à la sortie du restaurant mètres
du but fait un malaise et transporté à
l'hôpital pour un traumatisme crânien
poursuivi pour violences volontaires
ayant entraîné une infirmité permanente
l'accusé est classé en détention
provisoire cinq jours plus tard la
victime décède et les faits sont
requalifiés en violences volontaires
ayant entraîné la mort sans intention de
la donner
libéré après neuf mois de détention
l'accusé s'est dit aujourd'hui dépassée
par cette affaire est prêt à coopérer
mon épouse a manipulé tout le monde j'ai
vécu 23 ans avec elle je sais de quoi je
parle
on a quand même tout un débat qui est un
débat qui va avoir lieu demain avec des
experts qui vont nous décrire le
le traumatisme les lésions et les causes
de la mort tu sais qu aux allées sont en
lien direct avec les coûts que maître du
monde a pu recevoir cet après midi
l'audition des témoins n'a pas permis
d'en savoir plus sur les violences pour
lesquelles l'accusé est poursuivi
si ces faits sont avérés tout l'enjeu
est de savoir si ils ont été perpétrés
contre l'homme qu'il prenait pour
l'amant de sa femme ont contre l'avocat
une circonstance aggravante
dans le premier cas l'accusé encourt 15
ans de prison
dans le second cas il risque 20 ans de
réclusion